an energy crisis
a climate crisis
and an identity crisis
Europe's economy is at a turning point
I think Europe actually is pretty good
at when we have a bit of a crisis to do
something with it it's sad maybe that
you need to but I think that's you know
that's just part of reality as the war
continues to rage in Ukraine European
leaders are facing the challenge of a
lifetime
first there's the prospect of a winter
without rushing gas then there's a
skyrocketing cost of living an impending
recession and the economic threat posed
by extreme weather all this happening at
a time when the very notion of European
Unity is in question if there's an
emergency who do you call in the
European Union you don't call Brussels
you usually think about Paris or Berlin
in this video we'll take an in-depth
look at the state of the European
economy its greatest strengths and
biggest vulnerabilities in times of
Crisis we'll ask what it needs to do to
keep up with the likes of China and the
United States and whether National
differences can be set aside in favor of
a common purpose
that's all coming up on business Beyond
first let's get the basics out of the
way in this video we'll be talking a lot
about the European Union but also about
Europe as a continent it's an important
distinction so let's take a look at a
map
the European Union is made up of these
27 countries
the United Kingdom used to be an
important member but officially left the
Block in January of 2020. several more
countries are on some kind of a path to
membership these include Albania Moldova
North Macedonia Montenegro Serbia turkey
and most recently Ukraine
geographically though the continent of
Europe is much larger covering a total
of 45 countries including the Western
and most populous area of Russia
the European Union we know today has its
roots in an economic agreement on coal
and steel
in 1952 scarred by the horrors of World
War II West Germany France Italy the
Netherlands Belgium and Luxembourg
formed the European coal and Steel
Community
the idea was that if countries managed
these key Industries together no one
nation would be able to build weapons to
use against another
over the next few decades more countries
joined a club whose interests and
identity was moving far beyond coal and
steel in 1993 the single Market was
launched allowing the free movement of
people Goods services and money
further expansion followed and in 2002
the EU introduced a single currency the
Euro at present it's used in 19 out of
27 EU countries
since its Inception the European Union
has faced a lot of internal division
during the global financial crisis
countries disagreed over how to share
the costs of recovery richer more frugal
nations clashed with poorer more
indebted ones
then in 2016 brexit the United Kingdom
one of the most important members of the
EU voted to leave the block the decision
sent shockwaves across Europe and the
world
but none of these crises compare to what
happened on the 24th of February 2022
when Russia invaded Ukraine
for the first time in decades War had
returned to Europe
the reaction from the EU was decisive
and once again in the center of Europe
innocent women men and children are
dying
fear for their lives
we condemn this barbaric attack
and the cynical arguments to justify it
is President Putin
who's bringing War back to Europe
and in these dark hours
the European Union and its people
stand by Ukraine and its people
the eu's immediate response was indeed
United with countries agreeing to impose
economic sanctions on Russia and to help
millions of Ukrainian refugees if you
think about
Europe on the 23rd of February and today
the steps have been
gigantic and the shifts have been huge
but maintaining that Unity has proven a
challenge European countries have
different levels of Reliance on Russian
gas and some member states have been
less enthusiastic about imposing ever
more aggressive restrictions on Moscow
in the first months we saw a quite
compressive Unity of um of purpose and
also of willingness to um to put in
place um the the sanctions um but as we
got on to the sixth and um discussions
of the seventh um sections packages
um you can you can see that the sort of
the line between political costs at home
and uh perceived impact that the
previous rounds of sanctions packages
um were having
um in Russia was was perceived as being
kind of you know slightly on the wrong
side of what Europeans were comfortable
with um and you know there was a lot of
coverage of of some member states
um particularly Hungary
um
looking for carve outs and and slowing
things down but you know I think that
there was a sort of a general sense that
um we were coming to the um to the
limits of of what Europe felt it could
sustain politically
um because you know in in parts
um of rising Rising energy price at
prices and the cost of living which are
not only a result of the conflict but
that's played a major part even before
Russia's war in Ukraine life in Europe
had been getting more expensive as
covid-19 restrictions were lifted people
started spending the cash they'd been
hoarding during the pandemic that as
well as supply chain issues in China
pushed prices up but the war in Ukraine
has catapulted Europe into a full-blown
cost of living crisis
all over the continent people are
worrying about how to pay their bills
the Baltic states are at the Forefront
of the problem due to their close trade
Tides with Russia
but inflation has skyrocketed across the
board hitting figures that haven't been
seen in decades
[Music]
many national governments have a nice
relief packages to help households get
through winter still analysts believe
there could be unrest to come Rising
bills uh protests discontent these are
all likely
situations in coming weeks and months
this is likely to be a winter of
discontent but it's not just this winter
that matters the war in Ukraine has made
European leaders determined to wean
themselves off Russian energy for good
easier said than done
first of all it's a large thing to
replace so it's not easy I think people
are making quite large turns in policy
to basically throw everything at it you
know we do call a little bit we do
Renewables more and but we do kind of
everything
uh what I haven't heard is a more
structural solution that says you know
if we have to do it uh
um we will solve the supply more
fundamentally both with Renewables and
maybe some of the old technology with
some carbon capture or something like
that and that brings us to another
urgent challenge for Europe the climate
crisis this summer the continent was
struck by a severe drought causing
rivers to dry up and wildfires to spread
the hot dry conditions put a big strain
on shipping water levels in Germany's
Rhine and Italy's pole dropped so low
that larger ships were no longer able to
pass through
Farmers faced poor harvests and higher
production costs
against the backdrop of the energy
crisis leaders were forced to balance
immediate needs against long-term
climate commitments such as the green
deal The eu's Landmark planned to become
climate neutral by 2050. uh you know so
I think some of the Energy Efficiency
conversations that we've been having and
that we've seen over over the summer
um that you know we're a lot further
forward on some elements um uh than um
than we might not be um but I think that
what is
um under threat is the urgency around
the implementation of the the European
green deal from um from the European
point of view this has gone from being
you know I would say kind of yeah top of
the list a year ago being somewhere a
little further down in terms of
immediate security needs um at the
moment for European leaders and I think
that that is a problem but I think we
should go a little bit beyond the
present crisis to think you know long
term what does this mean
long term it means that if if European
countries and the EU are able to
um take advantage of the current crisis
and use it to
um accelerate the um a green transition
um that would confirm Europe's
leadership role in terms of climate
policy
um and it would give it give I think the
continent
um that step ahead with respect to the
rest of the world in leading
um Global
um the global fight against
um against the climate crisis and that's
um where Europe should look towards
um thinking about the future and if
Europe is to become a global leader in
the green transition it will have to
prove that it can innovate and in this
area it might have its work cut out
after all the continent doesn't exactly
have the best reputation for a while
getting things done
Sven Smith is the lead author of a
research paper about Europe's quote slow
motion corporate and Technology crisis
it suggests the continent could lose
between two and four trillion euros
worth of value every year unless it
plays technological catch up here's how
he reached that colossal number
and if you don't calculate through
sector by sector what will happen if
cars go autonomous and we don't lead in
that technology what will happen if AI
becomes the way to do research in life
sciences and we are not the leader in AI
and we take that disadvantage that
basically would cut back the growth and
prosperity of European firms with that
Europe
um by that amount just take a look at
this list list of the world's 10 biggest
tech companies seven come from the US
and three from Asia Europe doesn't
feature at all according to researchers
it's not for a lack of ideas
it's not that we're not innovative
we innovate we have lots of ideas we
have great talent that's not the issue
but the scaling is just harder because
you start in the Netherlands in Germany
Austria Spain
and then when you get bigger you find it
was somewhere else and then the big
player from somewhere else eats it
because they already have the larger
skill
so why is it so much harder for a
company to expand in Europe well imagine
you're a software developer they
typically have to wrote the code for
every country not just because of
language which is one but also some of
the rules on how a number is composed
in the phone system or in the banking
system or something will just require
you to write the code a few times which
means that even for the same dollar you
get less output
yeah that's just a very basic thing you
might think that makes no that should
make a difference but if you're a
five-person startup
that can write the code once and then
have a few hundred million customers or
you write the code once and you have and
you if you're in the Netherlands you
have you know 70 million if you're in
Germany you have 70 or 80 million you
know uh that makes a vast difference as
well as having trouble scaling their
business across Europe many
entrepreneurs also have trouble
attracting investment
one of the issues we have in the
European Union is also because of of the
different regulations and not the
different tax system that we have in the
27 member states is also quite
complicated to fund start Taps and to
attract Venture Capital which of course
is the basis of innovation the eu's
linguistic and cultural diversity is
often cited as one of its biggest
strengths but it's also the driver of an
uneasily resolved conflict between
National and European identities
that tension plays out in economic
narratives too the EU is the world's
third largest economy almost on a par
with China but you don't often hear it
described as a single entity that
tendency to favor National narratives
over a common European story has
implications when it comes to how the
continent is viewed on the world stage
to Europe but we compare a France to the
United States in France is because it's
another abroad nation and it has
something
white cultural people thought but you
shouldn't work Europe by only comparing
one country with Europe in total
it's not only languages and cultures
that may
equal to class Europe as a single entity
its policy too
on the one hand we have a common
monetary policy but we don't have a
common economic process now with the
pandemic European governments gave the
European commission the executive of the
European Union quite a bit of power and
quite a bit of of space to coordinate a
European wide response
um and and and this has introduced some
changes
um with the Recovery Fund for instance
and we what we don't know at the moment
is whether governments are willing to
extend that leeway that was given to the
European Commission in the context of
the pandemic also to address some of the
consequences of the cost of living
crisis so for instance we don't yet know
whether
um a European commission borrowing will
be extended Beyond 2022
while the EU faces a lot of internal
debate on issues like taking on and
sharing debt there is one Arena where it
negotiates as a single entity trade
the block has dozens of trade agreements
with countries all over the world
interestingly though it does not have an
agreement with its two biggest trading
partners China and the US
negotiations for the transatlantic trade
and investment partnership or ttip began
in 2013 but were abandoned in 2016 When
Donald Trump came to power
his presidency created a tonal shift in
discourse that left a once solid
transatlantic relationship in uncharted
waters
there's a lot of caution on on this side
of the Atlantic because
um I think all governments in Europe are
convinced that Biden or a Democratic
president will not win the 2024
presidential elections so what we're
seeing is a rather narrow window of
opportunity
um to get some things done get some
things done is number one solidify NATO
and that is happening accelerated very
much by Russians in Russia's invasion of
of Ukraine
um number two the transatlantic trading
Technology Council I think can could
potentially achieve some significant
results but I think also you know quite
candid
um quite a candid assessments that you
know the EU Europe as a whole
um cannot put all its eggs in one basket
and that is the American one
speaking of not putting its eggs in one
basket the European Union had also been
working towards reaching a deal with
China the comprehensive agreement on
investment had been eight years in the
making and was supposed to be given the
green light last year but it has yet to
be approved by the European Parliament
I think the comprehensive agreement on
investment is dead
[Music]
China or better some Chinese delegations
have tried and rephrased it some
delegations from China have tried to
revive it in informal conversations try
to see whether there was a future but
the European Parliament the factor froze
the process back in 2021 when the
European Union in China had that
exchange of sanctions and the European
Parliament has no intention at the
moment of voting for such an agreement
those EU sanctions she's referring to
targeted a handful of Chinese
individuals and entities accused of
being involved in the mass detention and
persecution of the uyghur ethnic
minority in the xinjiang region in
Northwest China
[Music]
they wear very weird sanctions
um from the European side they were
quite limited they targeted a limited
number of officials in in China and
China responded with this
wide sanctions that hit bodies and
institutes and single researchers and
single parliamentarians so to begin with
they were very unclear in terms of what
to expect from these sanctions and the
fact that they came basically still
during the pandemic also means that none
of the people who were sanctioned had a
chance to test them in terms of for
example applying for a Visa so we don't
know what what it means in that in that
regard what we know is that both sides
are trying to get them
eliminated with Europe's future
relationship with both China and the
United States up in the air some
economists say it's time to look for new
Partnerships if I speak about new
partners in the world for Europe
I think about Africa
Africa is a continent which properly
decides about the fate of Europe as it
faith of Europe economically as afraid
of Europe is in its
news role in the New World Order in
recent years the EU has signed several
free trade deals with African countries
many of them fall into the category of
economic partnership agreements African
nations benefit from zero tariffs and
full Market access in the EU in turn
they open up their own economies albeit
more slowly to the block
the volume of African European trade has
risen as a result including in the area
of agricultural equipment we can explore
technology but we should know that they
can improve it and that Africa has to
improve the Technologies because not
everything is optimal in Europe or
agricultural products are produced in
Europe is not optimal so we should look
for an equal footing strategy in Europe
with Africa and South Africa would
become a partner of Europe not a new
Colony again about the partner of Europe
whether it's looking for New Economic
Partners providing fertile ground for
Innovation or dealing with the energy
crisis this is a defining moment for
Europe's leaders and one which could see
the balance of power shifting between
member states in terms of leadership I
would say that you know we're well past
the Merkel era in which Germany had
uncontested leadership in Europe
with the election of Macon 2017 the sort
of shall we say unipolar German
leadership was already accompanied by
the Franco German relationship but I
have long argued that with a diverse
European Union franco-german leadership
is not is is necessary a necessary
condition but it's not a sufficient
condition for to to drive Europe it has
helped Europe overcome some of the gaps
that exists within its fold and
um and and I think they it really
underscores the need for a leadership
that is more Diversified that has that
gives a stronger role to Europe's
periphery that also gives a strong role
to the EU institutions
Italy's recent election of a far-right
coalition known historically at least
for its staunchly euroskeptic
nationalist rhetoric further highlights
the difficulty of advancing a common
European project
for European commission president urzila
Fonda line promoting a common agenda in
climate policy as well as other areas is
a delicate Balancing Act
we must be careful residents on the line
is going this way she knows where to go
she has a screen a pectin and so on
she's going about making your group
stronger but she's very careful but how
exactly would a stronger Europe look and
what role should it play on the world
stage there are a lot of things that the
EU is doing or planning to do
um on economic policy
um which will
um strengthen Europe's geo-economic
relevance we're looking at
um you know because of covids because of
U.S China rivalry also because of the
war
um European countries as a whole are
looking at what areas of their industry
are truly competitive speaking of
competing there are some vital areas
where Europe already is a world leader
the continent cities are consistently
ranked among the most livable in the
world
European nations also dominate the good
country index a measure of a nation's
positive Global impact in areas
including health and well-being
prosperity and peace and security
where we are saying we are more equal
and better and more stuff is that the
very bottom in in Europe is doing better
than the us but it's really only the
bottom 10 15
everywhere else the wealth is higher in
the U.S yes but life expectancy and some
sense of social cohesion and so on still
feel very much better and so it's very
interesting
said your European Union is now a larger
a higher life expectancy since in the
United States
United States had led a long time but is
a life expectancy is decreasing due to
obesity uh say it too much and due to
knock out the European Union as it is
today is in the in the elite
second only to Japan so what does the EU
have to do to convince its own people as
well as the rest of the world that it's
a force to be reckoned with we need to
strengthen National institutions for
democracy processes for Democratic
participation and and fireproof National
democracies uh before fireproofing the
European Union
um of course that you as a construct can
um can do with more reform but you're
not going to be able to achieve it if
you don't have National politics behind
the European project so we need to think
really in in in in simultaneous terms
it's not just about reforming the EU
it's also about strengthening
democracies at home
um and um and and and and and the
combination of the two can help
strengthen the eu's performance more
generally
the European project was born out of the
ruins of World War II
now more than three quarters of a
century later a new era of conflict and
crisis is forcing Nations once again to
Define what it means to be European and
crucially how to express that identity
in a radically different world
[Music]
and that brings us to the end of this
edition of business Beyond we'd love to
know what you think about Europe's role
on the broad stage let us know in the
comments and if you like what you see
here do check out the business Beyond
playlist a good place to start would be
our recent video on the U.S labor market
until next time from me and the team
it's goodbye and take care